[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 weekend comme tous
les vendredis vous le savez nous
revenons sur les moments forts de
l'actualité Culture Sport et Loisirs ça
y est nous y sommes le printemps est
enfin arrivé hier jeudi 20 mars c'était
également la journée mondiale du bonheur
et pour en parler nous avons reçu
l'auteur d'un livre qui s'appelle petite
philosophie pour grandir elle s'appelle
charlain guinoisau elle nous livre ses
petits secrets pour être heureux voici
un extrait évidemment dans cette journée
international du bonheur j'ai envie de
vous demander par rapport à ce livre
quelle est votre conception du bonheur
bien pour moi le bonheur ce serait
d'être soi et de d'être prêt à
accueillir la joie quand elle se
présente comme aujourd'hui ce grand
soleil vous êtes éditrice de métier je
le rappelle c'est votre premier ouvrage
en tant que auteur comment est venue
cette idée justement de cet envie
d'écrire ce premier livre et bien
j'écris depuis que je suis toute petite
dans mes carnets des poèmes plein de
choses et donc j'ai toujours eu envie de
d'évoluer dans l'univers du livre et de
l'écrit donc je me suis dirigée vers
l'édition de manière assez naturelle et
puis en fait ce livre je le porte en moi
depuis très longtemps depuis des années
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à l'enfance au
fait de grandir quand est-ce que on est
adulte est-ce que c'est une question
d'âge est-ce qu'on peut grandir
plusieurs fois dans une vie et donc
voilà dans le cadre de d'une collection
que nous lancions dirigé par Catherine
Rambert ce thème m'est apparu grandir
puisque je devais en choisir plusieurs
et je me suis dit que je ne pouvais pas
le ne pas l'écrire moi-même c'était un
peu une urgence pour moi vous l'avez
écrit d'ailleurs en très peu de temps en
2 mois le temps d'un été quasiment à
travers petite philosophie pour grandir
quel message vous voulez adresser à à
vos futurs lecteurs ah le message
premier c'est c'est vraiment d'être soi
et de ne pas avoir peur de d'accepter
ces blessures ses failles ces faiblesses
qui n'en sont peut-être pas d'ailleurs
et de vraiment de d'avancer de et de
faire de son histoire sa meilleure allié
par rapport à ce livre il y a plein
d'évidence en fin de compte dedans qui
sont semés un petit peu partout c'est
des évidences en fin de compte qu'on ne
auxquelles on ne pense pas dans le
quotidien non c'est un peu ça bien
parfois quand une chose est juste devant
nous on ne la voit pas et en fait
effectivement beaucoup d'évidence qu'il
est bon parfois de de se rappeler et et
d'en faire quelque chose à soi en fait
je le rappelle he ce livre est sorti il
y a quelques semaines dans les
librairies est-ce que justement cet
ouvrage vous a fait grandir un petit peu
d'une certaine manière oui oui et bien
oui puisqu'en l'écrivant forcément je
j'ai dû retourner en arrière dans ma
dans ma propre histoire et puis avancer
plus loin et et puis tout ce que ça
m'apporte aujourd'hui tous les tous les
messages que je reçois et cetera me faut
encore grandir et être avec vous ce soir
me fait grandir aussi pour préparer ce
journal évidemment je l'ai je l'ai
dévoré si j'ose dire puisqu'il est
vraiment très intéressant alors je vais
je vais en prendre une ou deux de
phrases que que j'ai trouvé
intéressantes on va les commenter si
vous voulez bien pourquoi sans vouloir
de pleurer chaque larme versée dessine
une marre de sel à nos pieds gment les
cortenasses dans nos souliers voilà de
pieds tout neuf pour avancer quel est le
message à le message et bien c'est que
quand on a vécu quelque chose de
difficile peu importe l'échelle de cette
chose c'est bien de pouvoir l'exprimer
et on se lave quelque part et et voilà
après on est on est prêt à avancer et à
accueillir le bonheur quand il se
présente et puis il y a une des
dernières phrases qui nous intéresse un
petit peu plus les journalistes qui est
assez assez drôle le savoir et la photo
d'un instant T une photo jaunie au
regard du lendemain chic de beau
reportages reste à venir j'avais pas
pensé à celle-ci bien oui puisquen fait
arrivé à la fin de ce livre je me suis
dit que si je l'écrivais dans 2 mois
dans 6 mois ou dans 10 ans il serait
différent et j'ai trouvé chouette de se
dire que justement c'était le dernier
message à apporter qu'on pouvait grandir
dire encore beaucoup que ce qu'on écrit
aujourd'hui n'est pas le reflet de ce
qu'on écrira demain et que donc tant
mieux il y a encore plein de choses à
[Musique]
découvrir
a en cour maintenant certains sont
partis à la découverte de l'espace
France Miniature a accueilli Jean-Luc
Pasquier porte-parole d'Astrium le
leader européen de l'industrie spatiale
c'était à l'occasion d'une animation
autour de la maquette Arian 5 Aurélia
debissi et Jonathan
vinman près de 450 kg de résine et 1500
heures de travail auront été nécessaires
à la fabrication de la fusée arienne 5
inaugurée en 2011 à France Miniature car
oui il s'agit bien d'une reproduction au
120e cette maquette de plus de 2 M60
était à l'honneur ce dimanche pour une
animation découverte de l'espace au
programme un quiz pour évaluer ses
connaissances et la rencontre avec un
expert spécialement accueilli par le
parc touristique pour l'événement tout
le monde est est fasciné par l'espace
jeanl Pasquier est là aujourd'hui pour
pour répondre à toutes ces questions
Arian 5 comment comment elle a été créée
et pourquoi et il apporte un peu plus de
précision sur l'espace maintenant je
voulais parler un peu de la Station
spatiale internationale est-ce que vous
connaissez oui dans gravity et ben on en
parle dans gravity absolument c'est une
bonne façon de connaître l'espace même
si tout n'est pas parfait dans gravity
il y a ici une magnifique maquette de
Arian 5 c'est c'est toujours une fusée
qui est importante pour pour l'Europe et
pour notre société puisque on est on en
est le fabricant elle est bien plus
petite que la vraie Ariane mais elle est
très
représentative dans dans dans tous ces
aspects hein on explique aussi ben les
les différents trop les utilisations des
satellites le fait que il y en a qui
sont en orbite très très basse et qui
servent par exemple à faire des photos
dans d'autres en orbite un peu moyenne
par exemple qui servent à la navigation
et puis d'autres sur la fameuse orbite
géostationnaire qui sont juste audessus
de l'équateur et qui servent
essentiellement pour les
télécommunications mission accomplie
après décryptage tout semble plus clair
pour ces jeunes visiteurs j'ai découvert
où se lancit les fusées comment était
fabriqué les fusé comment ça
décollait où ça été lancé pardon voilà
les animations sont sans supplément au
prix d'entrée du parc prochaine date à
retenir le weekend de pâqu ou le
chocolat sera bien entendu à la
fête ça dure jusqu'au 23 mars c'est un
événement national le Printemps des
Poètes le thème cette année au cœur des
arts plusieurs événements sont organisés
sur le territoire notamment à la ferme
de belbas à guillancour ce samedi une
journée entière de spectacle est
consacré à la poésie d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui Aurélia debiss a reçu sur
notre plateau Johann Lavabre directeur
et programmateur il nous donne tous les
détails l'idée c'est que le le
spectateur va grandir au fil des heures
on va commencer le matin avec des SPECT
ectle pour les tout petits à partir de 1
an alors justement c'est à 11h he le
premier spectacle c'est à 11h oui on
essaie vraiment de de caler l'heure en
fonction de de l'âge de l'âge des
spectateurs donc le matin c'est vraiment
le le meilleur moment pour les pour les
très jeunes spectateurs 1 an un ans 2
ans 3 ans mais jusqu'à 5 6 ans il y a
pas de souci et le spectacle s'appelle
bruissement c'est bruissement c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on y découvre alors c'est
un spectacle voilà pour cet âge là c'est
très très sensoriel il y a un arbre sur
scène un arbre sonore et il y a deux
deux comédiennes musiciennes qui qui
chantent qui qui murmurent qui voilà qui
c'est un éveille au sens en quelque s
oui c'est ça il y a vraiment au son au
son mais également enfin c'est c'est
très visuel c'est c'est très chanté très
chantonné un très joli spectacle voilà
pour les pour les tout petits ça peut
être l'occasion de de fréquenter une
salle de spectacle pour la première fois
de sa vie effectivement alors à 14h ce
sera allons enfants de la poésie alors
là c'est un spectacle dans lesquels sont
chantés et accompagnant en musique un
florilège de poèmes et donc de poètes
oui bah lesquel voilà alors c'est un
florilège de de de poème sur le thème de
l'enfance donc c'est c'est Fabi Lucienne
pardon des chants qui qui orchestre tout
ça et on entendra des poètes des poètes
vivants des poètes d'aujourd'hui il y
aura un petit peu de texte de Jacques
Prévert mais surtout Bruno douset David
duortier et évidemment Roland nado qu'on
ne présente plus à cqu en év ah bah on
va quand même un petit clin d'œil à
Roland nado donc ancien maire de Guillon
cour fondateur de la maison de la poésie
et de la ferme de BB absolument alors
donc tous ces ces poèmes donc seront lus
ou chantés par de des jeunes des ados
qui viennent je crois du club des jeunes
théâtrre et poésie oui alors Lucienne
Deschamps a invité effectivement avec la
Maison de la poésie de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline ce club théâtre et poésie et
voilà et quelques quelques jeunes
collégiens vont vont rentrer à
l'intérieur du spectacle et y particip
alors dès 16h on pourra retrouver alors
cette fois-ci ce sont les Fables de La
Fontaine mis en musique alors dans le
style de l'époque c'est-à-dire la
musique baroque absolument c'est un
spectacle proposé par Amal Alaoui qui
est une une chanteuse lyrique
spécialisée dans dans le registre
baroque et donc elle vient avec un
clavciniste une gambiste donc qui joue
de la viole de gambe et elle-même chante
et joue de la Flut à bec donc c'est une
plongée dans l'univers musical de Jean
de La Fontaine et on entendra donc les
les fables les fameuses fables euh qu'on
qu'on connaît tous qu'on apprend à
l'école alors du coupou oui voilà alors
le le corbeau et le renard voilà toutes
ces fables qu'on connaît très bien et on
les entendra mises en musique par des
compositeurs de l'époque de Jean de La
Fontaine euh voilà donc certaines fables
seront déclamées dans le style baroque
ça peut être un petit peu déroutant mais
c'est intéressant de montrer une œuvre
un petit peu dans dans son contextte
d'autres sont chantés et puis
progressivement le spectacle se se
décale un petit peu et on arrive vers
quelque chose de plus contemporain une
manière peut-être plus actuelle de dire
les textes euh une sorte de de
métamorphose en fait voilà du spectacle
absolument alors la poésie c'est vrai
que tous les publics n'y adhèrent pas
forcément est-ce que le fait que ce soit
mis en musique ça la rend plus
accessible bah c'est vrai que beaucoup
de gens ont ont peur de la poésie
beaucoup de gens ont l'impression que la
poésie ne s'adresse pas à eux c'est un
peu ellitiste parfois ou ben moi je
crois que les gens ont tort d'avoir peur
de la poésie je crois que surtout que la
poésie est très vivante et elle mort pas
donc faut pas avoir peur on peut s'en
approcher euh vraiment je crois que les
poètes s'adressent s'adressent au plus
grand nombre même si le plus grand
nombre s'en méfie mais c'est vraiment à
[Musique]
tort voilà donc pour vous une bonne idée
de sortie pour ce weekend vous pouvez
retrouver tout le programme sur le site
de la ferme de bbas le Solar Décathlon
de Versailles a annoncé le Parin de son
édition 2014 il s'agit du navigateur
Michel desjoyau un marin depuis
longtemps concerné par le devenir de la
planète Olivier manisalco et Jonathan
villman vous allez me dire le parallèle
entre les bateaux à voile et Solar
Decathlon en fait sur un bateau à voie
la force en compétition on est très
économe en
énergie Michel des jooyau Parin du Solar
Décathlon Europe de Versailles c'est
lors d'un point presse le 17 mars au
ministère de l'Égalité des territoires
et du logement que l'annonce a été
spalisé compétition internationale
d'architecture environnementale le
solarira en juillet prochain le meilleur
projet étudiant de maison alimenté en
énergie solaire le navigateur
finisterrien double vainqueur du vent
des globes a tout de suite adhéré au
projet et apportera outre sa notoriété
une conscience écologique qui ne date
pas d'hier moi j'ai tout de suite
embrayé sur la
proposition à titre perso tout
simplement parce que moi je suis
passionné de technologie d'innovation de
compétition aussi euh mais je suis aussi
tout simplement citoyen mes deux
dernières maisons sont sont équipées de
panneaux solaires thermiques même en
Bretagne il a assez de soleil pour
chauffer de l'eau euh et sur la
prochaine dont j'ai déposé le permis de
construire récemment j'ai bien
l'intention de mettre du solaire
thermique du solaire photovoltaïque de
de l'éolien de la récupération d'aut de
pluies pour la première fois organisée
en France la compétition accueillera du
16 juin au 19 juillet les projets de V
nation it différentes des projets qui
seront exposés au grand public durant 18
jours près du château de Versailles le
Solar va ainsi permettre un coup de
projecteur sur la maison écologique du
futur c'est le moyen de de montrer qu'on
peut construire différemment qu'on peut
améliorer des bâtiment existant et qu'on
peut faire beaucoup d'économie d'énergie
et utiliser les énergies renouvelables
dans le bâtiment et puis de montrer
aussi toutes les inventions toutes les
innovations qui sont en cours dans ce
secteur c'est c'est une bonne manière de
montrer effectivement qu'on est plus
seulement dans l'innovation l'innovation
est en train de de de découler dans dans
dans nos réalisations concrètes et c'est
nécessaire parce que la transition
énergétique c'est vraiment le challenge
du 21e siècle de notre continent et donc
de notre pays lors de ce solar Décathlon
Europe deux projets français seront
présentés en 2012 lors de la dernière
édition c'est un prototype grenoblois
qui l'avait
emporté ils sont huit coureurs
complètement amateurs et s'apprêtent à
réaliser leurs rêves participer à leur
premier marathon lors du marathon de
Rome le dimanche 23 mars immersion dans
leur préparation avec Anthony Resche et
Jonathan
villman ils effectuent leur dernier
footing comme pour se rassurer les
ultimes foulai avant la grande épopée
sur les routes italiennes Philippe Cathy
Christine et leurs partenaires se
préparent au marathon de rhum très
stressé j'ai des problèmes non pas de
sommeil mais d'intesta j'arrive plus
trop à manger donc c'est les nœuds au
niveau d'estomac mais bon on va y
arriver je ne dors plus je ne pense qu'à
ça j'ai même du mal à me concentrer
j'espère que mon patron me verra pas
parce que j'ai du mal à à à à me
concentrer sur mon travail je suis
concentré sur sur la la la performance
le trajet ell connaissent cette bande de
copains depuis plusieurs années pourtant
au départ Cathy et Christine n'adhèrent
pas du tout au projet elle faisait
partie des accompagnants mais tout
bascule lors d'une soirée de novembre où
l'entraîneur leur présente le projet
sportif et là je me suis dit euh
pourquoi ne pas le faire et je me suis
prise un peu au jeu lorsque alors je
suis assez challenge et lorsque le coach
a dit que sur la population française il
y avait à peu près un peu moins de
100000 personnes qui avaient couru un
marathon je me suis dit il faut que j'en
fasse partie le premier marathon on
cherche pas là on va pas chercher un
chrono on va surtout chercher à le finir
donc on a privilégié un petit peu les ce
qu'on appelle les sorties longues c'est
des sorties d'au moins 2h 2h3 c'estàd de
passer un cas psychologique de courir
longtemps avant cela il courait tous
ensemble une à deux fois par semaine de
depuis plusieurs années Gérard a donc
créé un planning personnalisé pour
chacun avec des séances de fractionné
adapté à leur capacité physique ah mais
je peux plus m'en passer c'est une
drogue ah oui oui tous les dimanches à
la même heure faut il faut aller courir
c'est oui c'est vraiment une drogue mais
pour franchir la ligne ce Ploton de
coureur devra surpasser le fameux mur
des 30 km une distance qu'ils ont
accomplie pour la première fois il y a
quelques semaines ça serait de le
terminer mais voilà secrètement je me
fixe 4h30 je va fixer le même objectif
que Philippe mais comme je cours
beaucoup moins vite que lui je me dis
que c'est peut-être un objectif un peu
un peu surréaliste donc je vais fixer
4h30 mais on va peut-être faire 5h ou
4h45 peut-être au-delà du chrono le plus
beau moment sera très certainement le
passage de la ligne d'arrivée qu'ils
espèrent tous franchir le 23 mars
prochain c'est un grand nom dans son
domaine Vincent Jaquet est le directeur
technique nationale de la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme notre journaliste
sportif Anthony Resche l'a rencontré il
dresse le bilan des championnat du monde
sur piste en Colombie où la France a
décroché C médailles dont trois en or
grâce au nouvelle li Montin François
Perville voici un extrait de leur
entretien Vincent Jaquet bonjour bonjour
à vous j'imagine que un peu plus de 10
jours après ces Mondiaux à Cali sur
piste le directeur technique national
que vous êtes est très satisfait après
ce bilan de médaille et de tites grande
satisfaction oui en peu le moins avec
quatre médailles d'or et les médailles
de bronze pour l'équipe de France sprint
par équipe c'est un bilan sportif tout à
fait satisfaisant qui place les équipes
de France à la place numéro 2 derrière
l'Allemagne au niveau de de l'échiquier
mondial donc sportivement parlant de
très beaux résultats évidemment on ne
peut pas parler des Mondiaux de Cali
sans parler de François Pervis le nouvel
innie Montin qui a qui est rentré tout
simplement dans la légende du cyclisme
sur piste vous avez raison je crois
qu'aujourd'hui François l'avait dit il
partait pour trois médailles d'or euh il
a il a eu ses trois médailles d'or c'est
en soi un grand exploit un exploit par
rapport à un athlète complet
physiquement mais mentalement parlant il
dit ce qu'il fait et il fait ce qu'il
dit donc aujourd'hui c'est une grande
satisfaction c'est c'est une base solide
et François n'est pas n'est pas arrivé
par là par hasard c'est la somme de de
d'années d'années de travail qui
aujourd'hui a fait exploser le le le
talent d'un d'un superbe athlète après
ces deux records du monde qu'on a connu
et vécu en 2013 c'est vrai que c'était
une belle revanche peut-être après sa
non sélection pour les Jos de 2012 il
s'est reconstruit mentalement et puis
maintenant il est devenu le leader à
contesté je crois que il l'a jamais pris
comme une revanche parce que François
est quelqu'un de de valeureux et
d'honnête il a pris comme un nouveau
challenge et dès lors que l'épisode
douloureux de Londres s'est imposé à lui
il avait déjà un coup d'avance il s'est
dit je vais profiter de la difficulté
des Jeux de Londres pour me reconstruire
pour me construire et encore être plus
fort il y a une petite surprise dans ces
Mondiaux de calis et Thomas Boudha qui
s'impose sur le M mais on n parlait pas
beaucoup avant de lui quand même alors
pour nous c'est pas vraiment une
surprise c'est une vraie
confirmation Thas avait besoin de de
croire en ses capacités d'avoir un
déclic mental il l' eu lors de ses
championnats du monde les phases de
coupe du monde qui se sont passé les
mois précédents ont été des révélateurs
pour lui il est clair qu'aujourd'hui il
s'est positionné dans le dans la
situation du leader et et le Deki s'est
opéré au championnat du monde à Cali
c'est un jeune plein de culot et
aujourd'hui son talent a vraiment
explosé sur ces Mondiaux il y avait
aussi l'équipe féminine qui est jeune on
sait que c'est une jeune génération quel
est votre avis sur leur performance de
Sandy claire Virginie QF notamment alors
on a deux athlètes à parentière qui qui
ont deux profils complètement différents
je pense que Virginie doit croire en ses
capacités réellement il faut qu'elle ait
le déclic ce qu'a eu Tomas Boudda il
faut que Virginie passe par là sandy est
une boscheuse sandy est une besogneuse
elle va avancer elle va arriver je dois
quand même souligner que même si elle ne
ne font pas podium même si elles ne
ramène pas de médaille elles sont quand
même dans leur meilleur temps des
disciplines sur lesquelles elles se sont
engagées donc le travail avance paye et
aujourd'hui elles évoluent
l'apprentissage est long mais leurs
résultats sont très bons oui un pour
rappel he Sandy a fini dans la finale du
Kin et puis Virginie QF 1e de finale
c'est une jeune génération qui continue
de progresser et qui va sûrement
progresser encore plus ici ouais je
crois que l'outil aujourd'hui c'est
indéniable va les faire évoluer vers le
mieux vers le plus et il faut que nous
avec avec le staff le coach et et
l'ensemble des personnes qui
accompagnent ce collectif qui soit
féminin ou masculin qu'on qu'on soit
capable de pouvoir les accompagner à à
vraiment performer et croire en leur
capacité et leur chance après c'est
mondiaux évidemment on peut que on ne
peut que louer ses résultats est-ce que
il y a une cohésion il y a une émulation
qui est en train de se créer au sein de
ce Team France de cette équipe de France
alors ça c'est tout mon c'est tout mon
job aujourd'hui on a des résultats mais
l'état d'esprit n'y est encore pas il
faut qu'on crée cette équipe on a de
fortes individualités on a des gros égos
à gérer on a à faire digérer aussi un
épisode dont on n pas parlé on en a
parlé pour François pour sa nonsélection
mais pour l'équipe de France sprint par
équipe buget d'almeda sirop on a encore
à faire digérer cette médaille d'argent
aujourd'hui on a faire évoluer aussi ces
individualités pour que lors des grandes
compétitions internationales on arrive
avec un groupe France et non pas des
noms au sein de l'équipe de France vous
le disiez il y a ce beloutil derrière
nous qui est le vélodrome de 50 ans en
yeline ça fait 2 mois et demi à peu près
que vous êtes installé ici est-ce que
vous sentez déjà un changement dans le
quotidien dans le travail dans la façon
d'évoluer alors le DTN oui les athlètes
oui évidemment mais c'est pas parce
qu'on a l'outil qu'on va être performant
aujourd'hui cet outil est un moyen d'Ar
arrivé à nos fins de podium et et
notamment de cet objectif Rio c'est
l'outil qu'il nous faut évidemment au
bout de 2 mois et demi on est encore
dans dans la zone de calage de réglage
et petit à petit nous allons arriver
dans le détail et et comme chacun le
sait le diable est dans le détail donc
si on arrive à à être performant dans le
PE plus petit dénominateur commun je
crois que cette dynamique autour du
vélodrome de 51 sera positive quoi qu'il
en soit les athlètes le disent à chaque
fois qu'ils viennent nous n'avons jamais
eu un outil de ce type et de ce haut
niveau de performance maintenant comme
je le disais précédemment c'est à moi
d'insuffler qu'il faut travailler qu'il
faut être plein d'abnégation qu'il faut
respecter l'ensemble du collectif pour
[Musique]
avancer tous les 2 ans le château de
Versailles accueille sur son grand canal
ces traditionnel rgat plus de 1200
rameurs s'étaient donné rendez-vous pour
tenter de s'imposer dans l'une des 15
courses os Anthony et Jonathan Vman
sétait rendu sur place 200 équipages une
course toutes les 4 minutes sur le grand
canal chaque coup de rame est donné sous
les fenêtres du château de Versailles un
spectacle quasi unique c'est super c'est
c'est assez beau en plus esthétiquement
c'est c'est parfait pour des jeunes on
est tout à fait surpris la vitesse à
laquelle ils pratiquent le leur sport et
le motivation laart les compétitions
françaises d'avviron sont amicales à
l'exception des championnats et des
épreuves de sélection autant dire que
les régates permettent de s'évaluer par
rapport à la concurrence ça peut être
des bateaux préparatifs pour les
championnats de France donc les quat de
couple les h donc en effet si c'est des
bateaux club qui vont se retrouver sur
les championnats de France et donc de
voir un petit peu quel est le niveau et
et éventuellement changer de catégorie
si on se dit bon bah non c'est pas ça
pour nous il y a trop de niveau ou si
vraiment il y a une une compétition
serrée et intéressante motiver les
rameurs pour la suite
au milieu des 1200 rameur le membre de
l'équipe de France Thomas Barou qui est
en LCE avec ses coéquipiers de club mais
problèm ils n'ont ramé que deux fois
ensemble cette saison lors des régates
versaillaises il s'assoit dans le bateau
pour le plaisir pour prendre aussi
quelques marques en vue des championnats
de France en juin prochain c'est
l'occasion de de ramer ensemble
effectivement on a un nouveau coéquipier
dans dans ce bateau parce que parce
qu'on a fait avec ceux qui pouvait être
présent cette
année voilà il va falloir encore
chercher des
des REP cet après-midi parce que le
bassin est un peu compliqué donc ça
c'est pas gagné si son calendrier lui
permet d'être présent reggat cette
saison Thomas Barou rame surtout pour se
faire une place dans le bateau olympique
du 400 barreur poids
léger allez on termine cette édition
avec votre traditionnel agenda ce samedi
22 mars la ville de trappe organise son
carnaval de printemps la compagnie
d'ifaco propose son défilé car
navalesque des ateliers de fabrication
de costumes ou encore des ateliers de
musique et de danse rendez-vous dès 16h
sur la place des merisier ce samedi 22
mars toujours du football américain les
Templiers d'élencour affrontent les
dauphins de Nice ce sera la 4e journée
du championnat de France élite coup
d'envoi à 20h c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité dès lundi à
18h d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend sur TVfil
[Musique]